Prof: Good morning
everybody.
Today I am going to--well
actually let me step back for a
second.
I have been mentioning to you,
in the last several weeks I've
been mentioning to you,
more than once,
the fact that we are--
we have been beginning to see
what I've described as the
baroque element in Roman
architecture,
the baroque element in Roman
architecture.
And I want to concentrate on
that particular aspect of Roman
architecture today,
which is why I've called the
lecture "Baroque
Extravaganzas."
I want to make--at the
beginning, at the outset,
I want to make a few points.
I want to highlight what I see
as the three major features of
baroque architecture in the
Roman period.
The first of these is that
those buildings that are
baroque,
or at least the architects and
patrons who designed buildings
that we think of today as
Baroque,
or we might define as Baroque
buildings,
they used the traditional
vocabulary of architecture;
vocabulary of architecture.
And by that I mean the
traditional vocabulary of Greek
and Etruscan architecture,
for the most part.
I'm speaking now of columns,
I'm speaking of pediments,
and I'm also speaking of
lintels and entablatures and the
like.
They use all of that
traditional vocabulary,
but they use it in a very
different way.
That's number one.
Number two is that ancient
Roman baroque buildings tend to
be decorated in a very ornate
fashion -- almost too ornate.
In fact, we'll see that these
buildings are covered with
decoration,
so much so that they seem to
dematerialize some of the
architectural elements,
including those ones that make
up that traditional vocabulary
of architecture.
The third, and in some respects
the most important,
is the fact that they use these
traditional elements of
architecture to--
they use them in a way to
enliven the surface,
to create motion,
to create a sense of
undulation.
And that in and out,
the in-and-out projection and
recession that I've mentioned on
a few occasions,
we see that interjected into
these works of architecture of
the so-called Baroque style.
So keep those three
characteristics in mind,
as we look at a host of
buildings today.
I also want to mention that
we'll focus primarily today on
the eastern part of the Empire,
where we see a particularly
large number of these baroque
buildings,
in large part because there was
a strong tradition in that part
of the world for using that
traditional vocabulary of
architecture,
because of the very strong
impact of Greece and of Greek
architecture,
and of access to high quality
marble,
from that part of the world,
which of course is needed for
columns and the like.
So we'll focus on the eastern
part of the Empire.
I also want to make the point
that when one thinks about
Baroque architecture,
in general, one thinks not of
Roman antiquity,
but rather of the seventeenth
century in Italy.
One thinks, in particular,
of two master architects,
two great architectural giants,
who were on the world stage at
that particular time.
And that is Bernini,
Gian Lorenzo Bernini,
and also Francesco Borromini,
Francesco Borromini;
Bernini and Borromini,
who were themselves rivals,
architectural rivals;
put up buildings in fact that
are often in dialogue with one
another.
I think in particular of the
Piazza Navona,
where we have Bernini's Four
Rivers Fountain,
and Borromini's Church of
Sant'Agnese there in Agone,
and the way in which they were
set up to speak to one another.
I don't know if any of you--I'm
sure many of you know the Four
Rivers Fountain,
where one of the rivers has his
hand up,
like this, to protect himself.
And the implication is he needs
to protect himself;
he's facing Bernini's building,
he's facing--excuse me,
he's facing Borromini's church,
and he needs to protect
himself;
that is, Bernini's river needs
to protect himself from
Borromini's church,
the implication being that if
he doesn't--
he needs to hold up his hand
because Borromini's church is
going to collapse,
because it's so poorly executed.
So this very interesting
dialogue between the two men.
And again we think of that
primarily when we think of
Baroque.
And just a couple of examples.
I show here--and I'll show you
a number of them in the course
of the lecture today,
especially Borromini's
work--but I wanted to focus
right at the moment on St.
Peter's, San Pietro.
You see it here,
St.
Peter's as designed--the dome
is designed, as we've discussed
before, by Michelangelo.
The façade design by
Carlo Maderno,
also a seventeenth-century
architect.
But most interesting are the
embracing oval arms of Bernini's
colonnade.
And you can see that so well in
the view on the upper left,
the embracing arms of that
colonnade,
and all the motion and the
in-and-out movement that we find
both on the façade and in
the embracing arms is
characteristic of
seventeenth-century Baroque
architecture.
But I want to maintain today,
as I've maintained in the
course of the semester,
that the Romans,
there wasn't anything that the
Romans didn't do first,
and that it is Roman baroque
architecture,
as we're going to define it
today, that had a huge impact on
architects like Borromini and
Bernini.
And I remind you of a couple of
instances of that.
Think back;
the whole idea of using
hemicycles,
curves in architecture is begun
by the Romans,
of course, in such buildings as
the Sanctuary of Fortuna
Primigenia at Palestrina,
where you see one of the
hemicycles up there.
And you'll remember that from
our discussion of the paper
topics,
that in Gerasa there was an
oval piazza or oval forum,
well before the oval colonnade
of Bernini.
So again, what I'm going to try
to demonstrate today is how
important this baroque
architecture in Roman antiquity
is,
not only in its own right,
but also as a model and a spur
to the architects of the
seventeenth century in Italy.
We have touched upon the
beginnings of Roman baroque
architecture--
incipient, we might call it
incipient Roman baroque
architecture--
in a few instances.
And I just want to remind you
of those today.
Think back to Second Style
Roman wall painting.
I remind you of the Room of the
Masks in the House of Augustus,
where you see this theatrical
façade,
done in paint,
that represents columns with
projecting elements or lintels
on either side,
and then a kind of a pediment
up above.
We saw our first explorations
of this kind of thing in
painting, already in 60 to 50
B.C., and then in this case in
the '30s to 20 B.C.
And we maintained at that point
that there was probably a direct
relationship between theatrical
architecture and these kinds of
paintings.
But we don't have much in the
way of preserved,
built architecture at that time
that partakes of some of these
characteristics.
But we think it's possible that
there may have been,
as I mentioned then,
some wooden,
some scaenae frons,
with these kinds of effects
done in wood,
that no longer survive today.
You'll remember also that we
looked at the Forum Transitorium
in Rome: the forum first of
Domitian and then completed by
Nerva.
And I show you a detail of that
again.
And this is when we really
begin to see,
in built architecture,
this move toward what we're
defining today as the baroque in
Roman architecture.
And you can see that what we
have here are the traditional,
the traditional vocabulary of
architecture:
columns,
in this case Corinthian
columns, with projecting
entablatures on top,
creating a system of receding
and progressing bays across the
surface,
which created a kind of
undulating movement across the
sides of the forum.
And then you'll remember also,
if you look at the frieze,
that the frieze continues along
the sides of the columns as
well,
and then in a relief of
Minerva, up on top.
It's not quite--I wouldn't call
it overly ornate quite yet,
but it is ornate.
And you'll remember that during
the Flavian period,
for example,
there was a lot of interest in
ornate decoration.
So we're beginning to see some
exploration of this kind of
thing.
And then it comes full-blown,
in the early third century
A.D., the Septizodium,
the façade that was
designed for Septimius Severus
to add to the Palatine Palace,
that had been built by Domitian;
this incredible façade
that is more show than anything
else.
We think it may also have
served as a fountain,
as I mentioned,
very much looking like a
theater set,
with three very large niches,
columns on the curve,
and then a series of columns,
placed in three tiers,
with wings on either side,
and we have a sense that this
too was quite decorative.
So all of those elements:
the use of the traditional
language of architecture,
columns, lintels and so on;
an interest in a very
decorative surface;
and then above all this
interjection of motion into the
structure--
projecting bay,
receding bay,
receding bay--all using the
traditional language of
architecture,
the traditional vocabulary of
namely columns and the like.
Then I also showed you the
tomb, the second-century Tomb of
the Caetennii,
under the Vatican in Rome.
And we looked at this
axonometric view in Ward-Perkins
showing the brick-faced concrete
façade,
with the exposed brick that was
popular at that time.
But we focused in on the
interior of the structure,
where I mentioned that through
architectonic means the
architects had embellished this
surface and created interesting
motion in that surface.
And you see here this same idea
of split--
as we see in the paintings of
the Second Style,
a triangular pediment has been
split apart to reveal another
triangular pediment inside,
with a niche,
as you can see,
and the rest of the wall
embellished with columns.
So once again this sense of
in-and-out movement,
across the sides of that
wall--walls.
And here you see a view of it
as it looks today.
The columns and so on are no
longer there,
but you can reconstruct them in
your mind's eye,
underneath these capitals,
and get a very good sense of
this articulation;
what we might call a kind of
baroque articulation of the
walls.
I mentioned already that most
of our best examples of Roman,
ancient Roman baroque
architecture can be found in the
eastern part of the Empire.
And I'd like to concentrate on
those today;
although we'll look--we won't
look at those exclusively.
I do have a couple of examples
from the West as well.
I'm going to actually start in
the West, at a place called
Santa Maria Capua Vetere.
And I show it to you on the map
here.
It is close to all the sites in
Campania that we've been talking
about this semester.
You see Pompeii and Herculaneum
and Oplontis and Baia,
for example,
and Benevento.
And over here Naples.
And you can see the proximity
of Santa Maria Capua Vetere,
to all of those that we've
already covered.
And in Santa Maria Capua Vetere
has been found an extremely
well-preserved Roman tomb,
and you see it here in the
center of the screen --
a Roman tomb that dates to the
late first century A.D. It is
very clear that it is made of
concrete construction,
and that it is faced with
opus incertum work,
which you can see here very
clearly.
But you can also see that some
brick has been used,
around the niches,
and as a molding,
both for these cylinders and
for the tholos above.
This has confused scholars.
They don't know when to date
this;
also because of these so-called
baroque characteristics where
you see this undulating
façade,
with the use of--well they're
not really columns,
they're more like cylinders,
and in that sense similar to
the cylinders that we saw in the
Tomb of the Baker,
these cylinders.
But the undulating
façade,
the use of architectural
elements, the interest in
decoration,
and the cylinders,
have confused scholars,
as I said, and they have been
betwixt and between when to date
this thing.
And some have said that it
dates at the time of such
buildings as the Sanctuary of
Fortuna Primigenia at
Palestrina,
because of the opus
incertum.
Others have said because of the
use of brick here--which we
actually think in this case was
stuccoed over--that it might be
later second century A.D.
But this is actually more like
the tile brick that we saw in
Pompeii, rather than the kind of
brick that we see in Ostia.
So I favor the first-century
date, late first-century A.D.
date.
But we have to think of it as
very prescient of what is to
come,
experimenting,
as did some of those other
buildings that I just showed
you--
the Forum Transitorium,
for example--
with the sort of thing that is
going to become particularly
popular in the second and third
centuries A.D.
Now I juxtapose this tomb--and
by the way,
this tomb, the nickname of this
tomb,
as you can see from your
Monument List,
is "La Conocchia."
La Conocchia means "the
distaff,"
and a distaff is used in
spinning and weaving,
a spinning thread primarily.
And it looks like an ancient
distaff.
So that's how it got its
nickname, La Conocchia.
Whether that means that that
was intended by the designers,
and that this was a tomb of
perhaps a woman who was--
or a man working in a factory
who spun thread.
I think that's very
far-fetched, I think it's highly
unlikely, but I just throw it
out there.
But that is what its nickname
is.
But you can see by the
juxtaposition of it with the
Tomb of the Baker on the right,
and with the Monument of the
Julii in Saint Rémy,
in the south of France--which
we haven't looked at,
but which we will look at in a
lecture next week on Roman
architecture in the south of
France,
primarily--you will see that it
makes reference to both of
these.
Both of these are earlier.
This is, as you know, Augustan;
the one on the left is from the
late--the time of Julius Caesar.
And you can see that it takes
elements--
I'm not saying it looked at
these in particular,
but just that these kinds of
elements were already in the air
when this building was built,
in the late first century A.D.
The great cylinders of the Tomb
of Eurysaces.
But it is more similar actually
to this one, because the Julii
Monument, and also La Conocchia,
are examples of what we call
the tower-tomb type.
The tower-tomb type is taller
than it is wide.
It has a series of stories,
in this case a plain story,
then a central story,
with the cylinders,
and then the tholos at
the top.
And we see the same sort of
thing in the Julii Monument:
stepped base,
socle here with sculptural
decoration,
a quadrifrons,
and then a tholos at the
very apex.
But it's interesting to see the
differences between the two,
because what we see in this
monument again is much more what
we would call baroque,
in the sense that we have the
undulating façade,
we have the use of what looked
like,
in a general way,
the traditional vocabulary of
architecture,
with these cylinders,
with the niches,
with the pediments.
But look at the way the
tholos is treated.
When you look at the
tholos in the Julii
Monument,
you see that it really does
look like a shrine,
and it has statues inside,
like a shrine would.
This one has blind windows,
as you can see.
You can't see into it;
there's nothing inside.
So they're treating the
tholos more as a
decorative motif than they are
treating it as something that
has the purpose of holding some
either religious items or
statues or honorific statues,
as it does in this particular
case.
Another view of La Conocchia,
a detail which I think shows
you what I mean about motion
being introduced into monuments
like this.
In this case we are dealing
with concrete,
and that is somewhat different,
the use of concrete to create
undulation,
than the use of the traditional
vocabulary of architecture.
But here we see a combination:
the concrete wall,
faced with the opus
incertum,
the great cylinders on the
edge, and then the
aedicula here,
with the pediment and the niche
below.
And you can also see very well
the cylinders that are located
between the blind windows,
as well as this combination of
opus incertum work,
and also the tile brick that is
used to represent the moldings
and the like.
I want to compare the central
zone of La Conocchia with a
seventeenth-century Baroque
building in Rome.
This is Francesco Borromini's
Sant'Ivo in Rome,
taken from an angle that
accentuates the curvature of the
façade,
and the contrast between the
concavity of that curvature and
the convexity of the outside of
the dome,
that you see up above -- the
same sort of thing here.
So once again architects of the
seventeenth century very much
inspired by these kinds of
motifs that survived from Roman
antiquity.
On the left-hand side of the
screen--you'll all remember
this;
this is the elliptical fountain
from the Palace of Domitian on
the Palatine Hill that was
located--
that he could see,
through his window,
out of the triclinium,
when he dined.
And you'll remember here also
in this case made out of
concrete construction,
designed by Rabirius.
You see the elliptical wall and
the convexity of that elliptical
wall;
the central element also
convex, but with these
interesting concavities,
scallops, that Rabirius has
created,
through concrete faced with
brick around the structure.
So in that case--all I'm trying
to do here is show you that you
can create similar effects,
either in concrete or through
columnar architecture.
But what separates
revolutionary concrete
architecture,
as we've discussed it today,
and baroque architecture,
as I'm going to define it this
morning,
is that in baroque architecture
they're relying on the
traditional--
not on concrete--but on the
traditional vocabulary of
architecture--
namely, of course,
columns, pediments and the
like--
to create their effects.
A place where it all comes
together you'll recall is at
Hadrian's Villa at Tivoli.
We're looking here at the
Piazza d'Oro,
a plan of the Piazza d' Oro:
the octagonal vestibule,
the great open rectangular
space that you can see here,
and then the aula or the
audience hall on the far right.
And you'll remember the
aula had these wonderful
undulating walls.
But what separated the
aula from other
undulating walls that we had
seen earlier is that it was not
done with concrete,
but was done with columns.
You'll remember the columns
were placed in such a way that
they followed the curved shape,
and then they supported a
concrete dome.
So this wonderful combination
of the use of traditional
language of architecture,
along an undulating form,
and then with concrete at the
top.
So we can see already in the
Hadrianic period further
exploration of this kind of
thing.
I also want to show you a very
interesting painting,
painted room,
and this is in the House of the
Labyrinth at Pompeii.
It's early in date;
it dates to 50 B.C.
But it's an extraordinary room.
It's the atrium of the house.
And we talked about several
different kinds of atria.
We talked about the atrium that
had no columns at all,
and we talked about the
tetrastyle atrium which had four
columns around the central
basin.
What you see here are a host of
columns surrounding that central
basin.
And when you have a number of
columns like this,
more than four,
we call it a Corinthian atrium
-- a Corinthian atrium with lots
of columns.
And what you can see the artist
and patron have done here is to
orchestrate the relationship of
those real columns with the
fictive architecture that is
painted on the wall,
and to play them up in such a
way that as you're standing in
the room you are looking through
the real columns to see this
view that lies behind of a
tholos which you can view
through the broken triangular
pediments.
I show it to you for a couple
of reasons: one,
just to remind you that we saw
this kind of thing in painting
very early on:
this is again 50 B.C.,
in the Republic still.
As we see, the architects
taking the traditional
vocabulary of architecture and
playing with it,
breaking it up,
opening it and revealing
something that lies behind,
in this case the tholos.
But look also at the way in
which the tholos looks
like it's in the distance.
You get the sense that you are
looking through an opening in
the wall, a window in which you
can see that tholos.
It seems to lie behind the
broken triangular pediment.
The pediment has been broken
open to allow you to see a vista
that lies behind,
and you get the sense,
as you look at this painting,
that the tholos is
surrounded by a peristyle,
and that there's also some
greenery and so on out there.
And then to accentuate this
idea of the view through the
wall,
they have then added the
columns here,
so that you're looking through
real columns,
to fictive columns,
to broken triangular pediment,
to the tholos that lies
behind.
You'll see the relevance of
this when we look at some
additional monuments.
I want to move--I want to now
go now east to look at some of
the most spectacular examples
that survive of what we are
calling baroque architecture in
Roman antiquity today.
And I want to begin in a site
that is in modern Jordan.
I'm showing you a map of the
Eastern Roman Empire,
and we see the site in
question, Petra,
or some say Petra:
you can call it either one,
Petra or Petra.
You see Petra over here,
which is in Jordan today.
And you can see its
relationship to the Red Sea,
to Egypt, to Alexandria,
to Judaea,
modern Israel,
and to some of these other
sites --
one, in fact,
a couple of others that we'll
look at,
Baalbek, today,
and the site of Gerasa,
which is where that oval pizza
or forum comes from.
Here's another map of Petra,
just to show you where it is
located today,
within Jordan,
its relationship to Amman,
and to the ancient site of
Gerasa --
as you can see up at the
bottom, fairly close to the
Israeli border,
as you can see,
as well as to Aqaba down below.
Just to get you in the mood for
Petra, we are walking here.
There are incredible cliffs
here, as well as desert,
incredible cliffs,
and we're walking here through
what is known as the Siq in
Petra.
And I want to mention that this
is one of those interesting
provinces where in order to
understand the architecture that
was built during the Roman
period,
you have to have a sense of the
local customs,
of what happened here before,
the buildings that were built
prior to the Roman period.
And we know that the so-called
Nabataeans--
n-a-b-a-t, nabat,
n-a-b-a-t, Nabataeans,
a-e-a-n-s, Nabataeans--lived
here, inhabited this part of the
world,
before the Romans got there.
And we know that the Nabataeans
built architecture,
and that they built
architecture primarily out of
the stone of the cliffs,
and also out of mud.
And one can imagine the kinds
of things that you see here,
the rock-cut tombs,
already begun during the
Nabataean period.
And it's interesting,
if you look very closely at
some of the detailed decoration
here,
you can see something that any
of you who wrote your paper on
the Temple of Bel at Palmyra
remember,
the sort of stepped,
the stepped motif decoration.
We see the same sort of thing
here.
But just important for you to
know that the Nabataeans were
building with stone and with mud
before the Roman period,
and so when the Romans came in
and began to build their own
architecture,
obviously the impact of what
had been built there earlier had
made an impression on them.
They too decided to build their
tombs out of the living rock of
Petra,
and they are among the most
spectacular and unusual tombs
that survive from the Roman
period.
And I want to show two of them
to you today:
the so-called Deir,
D-e-i-r, and the so-called
Khazne, K-h-a-z-n-e.
We will look at both of them,
with the Deir first.
And if you look at the Deir,
and the way in which it has
been created by carving it out
of the living rock,
you should not only be
impressed, but you should say to
yourself,
"Wow, this is Roman
facadism at its greatest,"
at its most obvious as well.
This is really Roman facadism,
because all there is is the
façade,
there's nothing else.
The tomb itself is located
inside the rock.
The tomb chambers are inside
the rock.
They didn't do anything to them
except hollow them out --
nothing much else there.
They've concentrated all of
their efforts on the
façade,
which seems to grow out of the
rock, almost as if by nature.
And if you look at this tomb,
the Deir,
you should also be struck
immediately by the way in which
what the Romans have created
here is a version in built
architecture of what we saw
already in 60 to 50 B.C.
in Second Style Roman wall
painting.
It is exactly the same kind of
thing: this idea of breaking a
triangular pediment open to
reveal a tholos that lies
inside,
in this case on a second story.
We see all of the elements that
I've already mentioned,
or most of the other elements
that I've already mentioned.
We see here,
in this façade,
the use of the traditional
vocabulary of architecture:
the columns,
the entablature above,
and pediments and so on down
here,
triangular pediments down here.
We see all of those,
but used in a way that the
Greeks would never have done.
And we see less in this one.
I'll show you better examples
of this interest in over
ornamentation.
There is ornamentation here,
but it's actually fairly
simple.
So this one doesn't partake of
that, as much as others that I
can show you.
But it does definitely,
by using the traditional
vocabulary of architecture;
the surface is enlivened by
creating elements that project.
Look at these columns on either
side,
with their projecting
entablatures,
standing alone--or more
pilasters than columns in this
case--
standing alone,
projecting--a receding bay,
a projecting bay,
a receding bay,
a projecting bay--
instilling motion across this
surface,
by means of the traditional
vocabulary of architecture,
again in this case on two
levels.
Here's another view of the
façade of the Deir,
on the left-hand side of the
screen,
and you can see the material
used is obviously the rock
itself.
This has been literally carved
out of the living rock,
so that it's obviously the same
stone and the same color as the
rock that still serves as its
backdrop.
And then over here,
the House of the Labyrinth
again,
just to show you again the
close resemblance of this sort
of thing in the mid-second
century A.D.,
in what is now Jordan,
to Second Style Roman wall
painting.
And I show you again the
tholos within the broken
triangular pediment.
But the main difference between
the two--
and here is where we do get
into this whole concept of
decoration and even over
decoration--
the main difference between the
two is when you're standing
again in the House of the
Labyrinth,
looking through the actual
columns,
toward the painting,
and you see that the triangular
pediment has been broken to
reveal the tholos,
as I mentioned before,
you still have a sense of space
and you still have a sense of
reality.
Even though the pediment has
been broken,
you seem to be--you are looking
at a tholos,
and you're meant to think that
that tholos lies inside a
peristyle court,
or a garden,
that is outside the house,
that you're seeing through a
window.
So you read the tholos,
or at least I read the
tholos,
as further back than the broken
triangular pediment.
That is entirely different here.
Yes, there's a tholos;
yes, there's a broken
triangular pediment.
But the tholos has been
turned into a decorative motif,
among many.
It is a tholos,
yes, but it doesn't look like a
working tholos,
so to speak.
You can see that it has a niche
in the center of it,
just like the other bays have
niches that probably held a
statue.
But you don't have a sense that
there is any space in there.
It is a decoration on the
surface, on the façade,
of this structure,
just like all the other
decorations.
And that is a major difference
between the way in which the
tholos is used in the
Deir and the tholos is
used in typical Second Style
Roman wall painting.
You may also have noticed some
of the decoration;
and I'm going to show you some
details now, so that we can look
at those together.
Here you get a very good sense
of the color of the stone,
of the rocks,
of Petra.
But you also see here a capital
that is unlike any capital that
we have seen before.
And this is where we see the
influence of the Nabataeans.
The Nabataeans were building
buildings that had capitals that
looked this,
sort of interesting undulating
capitals,
but very plain:
plain with a concave side and
then a kind of knob in the
center,
as you can see here.
These are Nabataean capitals,
and in this mid-second century
A.D.
tomb you can see that they are
looking, they're clearly looking
at models from Rome.
They are clearly looking at the
kinds of paintings that I have
already reminded you of,
but at the same time--or let's
say drawings made from those
paintings that are circulated,
or the architects may have
access to.
But they are combined with
local elements,
in this case the Nabataean
capitals.
And then if you look at this
detail over here,
you will see that they've used
a kind of triglyph and metope
system,
with the panels and then the
triple striated bands that we
saw was characteristic of Greek
Doric architecture;
that's used here.
But look at what's in the
metope.
We don't see anything like this
in Greek or Roman architecture;
the metopes,
in fact, in Greek architecture
are usually filled with figural
scenes, figural panels.
But here we see these large
disks, and a disk in each one of
these square panels.
These are Nabataean disks.
They are used in earlier
Nabataean architecture.
So once again this very
interesting and very fruitful
coming together of Nabataean
elements and of Roman elements
in this extraordinary tomb of
the mid-second century.
And then I show you,
on the left-hand side of the
screen, the finial that caps the
tholos.
And a fellow sitting over here,
at the base of the finial,
is very helpful to us because
he gives us a sense of human
scale.
This is this man;
he's small compared to the
finial.
So you can imagine how small he
is in relationship to the tomb
as a whole.
So once again bigger is better
reigns supreme in Jordan,
as it did in Rome,
where we can see that the
Romans are building very large
in the second century.
If we look at this finial here,
this decoration at the apex,
we see that they have used one
of these Nabataean capitals
again here,
and that that supports a kind
of fat vase on the top,
with a top on it.
And that, you see that sort of
thing in Roman art;
you see it sometimes in Second
Style Roman wall paintings.
It's probably a Greco-Roman
motif that has been combined
with the Nabataean capital here.
And you can also see,
from looking at this,
as well as the tomb as a whole,
that the architect is really
treating these buildings almost
more as sculpture than as
architecture,
molding them in a way that a
sculptor might.
And that's not so different
from what we saw Rabirius,
for example,
doing in his octagonal room and
in the fountain at the Palace on
the Palatine Hill.
Here again Borromini,
Francesco Borromini's Sant'Ivo,
the uppermost part of that,
just to show you again the
kind--these are by no means
exact;
there's no exact relationship
between these two at all,
and this one has different
features than that.
But just to show you that it's
this kind of thing that
unquestionably inspires
architects like Borromini in the
seventeenth century in Italy to
create the kind of lanterns and
so on that they do for the
churches that they design.
Here's another interesting
comparison.
This is a wonderful view of the
Deir in Petra,
which shows you I guess best of
all the way in which it is
carved out of and still embedded
into the rock of Petra itself;
magnificent.
And I compare it here too to
another Borromini church.
This is the famous Church of
San Carlo alle Quattro Fontane,
better known as San Carlino,
the Little San Carlo,
San Carlino,
as you see here.
And you see what Borromini has
done.
He has the undulating
façade--
he's using the traditional
vocabulary of architecture,
just like these architects are,
these nameless architects are:
the columns and the
entablatures and the pediments,
and so on and so forth.
He's using all of those here.
He even has a tholos in
the second--in the upper story,
right there.
And he is also very taken with
the whole idea of an actual
undulating wall,
as you can see also in this
view.
But he is doing the same sort
of thing that we see architects
doing here,
and I don't think there's any
question that the sort of
building that we see on the
right,
the Deir, had impact on
architects in the seventeenth
century.
We know that some of them
traveled to this part of the
world.
We know that drawings were
made, that books were made,
that these were brought back,
these were seen by people in
Rome in the seventeenth
century--
and of course they had local
things to see as well in Italy--
and that they were influenced
by what they saw.
The other rock-cut tomb,
the other very
impressive--there are many of
them in Petra;
I'm only showing you two out of
a fairly nice variety.
But I want to show you the
other most famous one,
the Khazne in Petra.
It also dates to the mid-second
century A.D.
Once again carved out of the
living rock.
Once again pure facadism;
this is nothing more than a
façade.
You can see how in this
case--once again two-storied--
a very similar scheme to what
we saw at the Deir--
two-storied,
with a temple front down below
and a tholos above,
that is revealed by the
splitting of the triangular
pediment,
as you can see well.
Once again the tholos
definitely treated as a
decorative motif.
Yes, in this case it has a
statue on a base,
but a statue on a base that is
not a real statue on a base,
carved onto the stone.
So once again we get a sense
that this is a decorative motif
rather than an actual statue
standing in the tholos,
and the same for the items on
the bases on either side.
You can see the triangular
pediment very well.
You can see the way it has been
split aside to reveal the
tholos.
You can see down below a real
temple front,
in this case.
This one is much closer to its
Roman prototypes,
in the sense that even the
decorative motifs are Roman.
Unlike in the Deir,
where we saw the Nabataean
capitals and the disks,
here we see actual versions of
the Corinthian order used;
the Corinthian order used here.
This looks very much like a
real temple front,
with an actual pediment;
sculptural decoration,
a frieze as well.
We're beginning to see,
in this one,
not only the use of the
traditional vocabulary of
architecture,
and not only the enlivening of
the surface using that
traditional vocabulary of
architecture through these--
in such a way that it creates
motion--
projection, recession,
projection, recession--
but we also are seeing here,
in a way that we did not in the
Deir,
this interest in excess
ornamentation:
ornamenting every surface that
you possibly can,
with sculptural friezes,
with pedimental sculpture,
with statuary carved into the
stone in all of the niches.
But then again,
a much closer relationship to
earlier Roman precedence by the
temple front,
by the use of the Corinthian
order.
But this one too,
a very similar finial at the
top of the tholos,
but using a kind of Corinthian
capital, with one of those vases
on top;
vases, by the way,
that we often see in Second
Style Roman wall painting.
Once again, one could come up
with a lot of comparisons for
the Khazne with monuments,
with seventeenth-century
Baroque buildings in Rome.
This may not be the best,
but it's one of my favorites
and I decided to show it in this
context.
But it's the Church of Santa
Maria--it's right near the
Piazza Navona--Santa Maria della
Pace, designed by Pietro da
Cortona.
Same sort of idea;
you know, the temple front down
below.
Yes, this is a different kind
of temple front,
because it's a round temple and
not one with a pediment.
But the same general idea of
having a temple front below,
and then a second story above,
all of this enlivened with
traditional vocabulary of
architecture--
columns, columns,
pilasters, a window in the
niche,
right up there a very
interesting segmental pediment
inside a triangular pediment.
Just to show you that this kind
of experimentation that we see
in seventeenth-century Baroque
architecture,
mostly in church building but
also in palaces,
is so clearly inspired,
let's say, by the baroque
architecture of Roman antiquity.
A couple more details here.
Here's a wonderful view from
down below showing you the
tholos of the Khazne at
Petra,
and comparing it to,
once again, some of the
confections of baroque
architects in Rome,
of the seventeenth century,
namely Sant'Ivo again,
with its curved façade
and wonderful eight-sided dome,
and some of the interior
decoration also of Sant'Ivo
above.
Staying on the--staying in the
Eastern Empire,
I want to go now to ancient
Asia Minor,
to two sites on the coast,
on the western coast of what is
now Turkey,
Ephesus and Miletus,
Ephesus and Miletus.
And I want to begin in Ephesus,
to show you one building there
of considerable interest I
think, in terms of its
relationships to Rome.
It is the Temple of Hadrian,
so called, that dates to around
120 to 130 A.D.
in Ephesus.
We know Hadrian visited Ephesus.
We know that those who lived
there wanted to honor him by
building a temple to him.
It is actually more a shrine
than a temple.
This is not a bigger is better;
this is actually a fairly small
structure, as I said,
more a shrine than it is a
temple.
It's a kind of street side
You're walking along the street
and then there,
all of a sudden,
it is.
But what's interesting about it
is the fact that it makes use of
the arcuated lintel,
as you can see here,
straight and curved,
just as we saw it used at the
Canopus at Hadrian's Villa.
So a motif that we see in
Italy, being used also in Asia
Minor for another Hadrianic
building --
so it's becoming associated,
in the minds of designers,
with Hadrian himself.
So traditional vocabulary of
architecture,
but used in a different way,
by using the straight and
arcuated lintel together.
This is a very good example of
this interest in
over-ornamentation.
Every single square inch is
used by the architects to
decorate: as you can see,
the architrave and also the
lintel in the back and the
pilasters in the back,
all of them decorated to the
point where the decoration
almost dematerializes the
architectural members.
Another detail where I think
you can see that particularly
well,
here on the right,
this dematerialization of the
architectural members through
sculpture.
And you'll remember this same
approach in the Severan Basilica
in Leptis Magna.
This is a detail of the piers
that we believe were added
during the time of Caracalla --
so around 216 A.D.
Obviously much later in date,
but we see already here this
interest in this sort of thing,
that's going to culminate at
places like Leptis.
And also just to make the point
that this same use of the
straight and arcuated lintel,
that we see in Hadrianic
architecture,
turns up also in
seventeenth-century Baroque
Rome.
I show you the interior of San
Carlino here,
where you can see again the
straight and arcuated lintels
combined.
So clearly seventeenth-century
Baroque architects looking back
at Roman examples.
I want to show you briefly a
gate at Miletus,
also, as you saw,
in ancient Asia Minor.
It's the gate to the South
Agora or marketplace of Miletus,
and it dates to around A.D.
160.
It is no longer in Miletus.
It was moved some years ago,
as antiquities sometimes are,
from its country of origin to
Germany.
It now can be seen in the
museum in Berlin.
They also have a great model in
Berlin that shows you the
relationship of the gate to the
rest of the Roman city;
and you can see the gate way up
there.
An incredible showpiece for the
city, this gate that allowed one
to enter into the South Agora.
I show it to you as
reconstructed in the museum in
Berlin.
It is quite an impressive piece.
You can see here,
it is that, it is a gate,
and it shows that you could
apply these baroque facades to
just about any kind of
architecture.
You see that the gate has a
triple opening down below,
three blind windows on top.
It is made entirely out of
stone.
It uses the traditional
vocabulary of architecture:
columns and capitals.
You can see the capitals in
this case are--seem to be
composite capitals.
And it is very much the
theater, the theater scaenae
frons idea,
with a series of projecting
elements on top of two columns,
with wings on either side,
also projecting.
Down below, the lintels are
straight,
but up above they have combined
full triangular pediments in the
wings,
with a broken triangular
pediment in the center.
And the broken triangular
pediment in the center is
particularly interesting,
because you can see the two
sides, left and right,
up above.
But you can also see that
they've included the center of
the pediment,
but in a plane that is further
back.
So you get this kind of zigzag
motif,
where you begin--the pediment
begins in the front zone and
then zigzags to the back zone,
which injects even further,
even a greater motion,
into the overall scheme.
Once again we see the
projection, the recession,
projection, recession,
all using the traditional
vocabulary of architecture.
It's interesting to compare
this to a much earlier gate in
Greece.
I show you the Propylaia,
the gateway to the Athenian
Acropolis, fifth century B.C.,
where you can see it's all
function.
They've used the Doric order
here, and the columns support
the roof above;
triglyphs and metopes.
The whole idea--it's very
beautiful--but the whole idea is
to use these columns
functionally.
Very different in this gate in
Miletus,
in the second century A.D.,
where you can see that the
columns are no longer used for
structural purposes,
but mainly to decorate and to
enliven and to add motion to the
structure in a way that is
entirely out of keeping with
these important Greek
precedents.
Here you see a detail:
some tourists looking at this
and other things,
in the museum in Berlin,
which gives you again a sense
of the colossal scale of this
structure.
Here you can see also very well
the composite capitals,
as well as once again this
interest in an almost overly
decorative surface that is so
characteristic of baroque
architecture.
A number of you embarked on the
Library of Celsus as your paper
topic;
so I'm sure you know everything
there is to know about that.
But I want to show it to you
quickly, in the context of this
lecture, because it's an
important monument for all of
you to be aware of.
Lest you think that it has
always looked the way it looks
now,
I show you a view that was
taken, well by now twenty-five
years ago or so,
before the building was
re-erected,
which it has been since then.
The building--this is what the
Library of Celsus looked like
twenty-five or so years ago.
But fortunately,
even though everything had
fallen down, it was all there,
as you can see.
There were fragments strewn
everywhere: hundreds and
hundreds of fragments strewn
around the site,
and enough fragments so that
basically the building was
there.
And what they eventually
decided to do was use those
fragments to re-erect it,
which took a number of years.
And the results have been truly
spectacular.
I show you a view of Ephesus as
it looks today,
looking back toward the
re-erected Library of Celsus,
and then a better view here,
where you can see what all of
those pieces,
the giant jigsaw puzzle that
all of those pieces ultimately
made.
You can see here this
incredible façade of the
Library of Celsus in Ephesus.
And you can see the scheme is
the same as I've just showed you
in the South Agora Market Gate
at Miletus, in this case two
tiers.
The bottom tier is very similar
to what we saw there,
just two columns supporting a
straight entablature above.
And then in the second story,
the addition of more decorative
elements,
with segmental,
two segmental pediments
flanking a rectangular one in
the center,
with separate individual
columns at either end,
like we saw in the Deir,
with supporting projecting
entablature.
Once again using the
traditional vocabulary of
architecture to create motion
across the surface:
projection, recession,
projection, recession.
But here, one very interesting
feature is that if you look at
the second story and the
placement of those second story
elements on top of those below,
you can see that the ones at
the top are not directly above
the ones at the bottom,
as we saw in the market gate,
but they straddle the space
below,
which is very interesting.
So instead of having the two
columns,
with a pediment above,
right above this,
you can see the columns with
the pediment above are right
above the space,
so they're straddling the
spaces.
Which, if you look at it for
awhile, you'll see adds an
additional sense of motion to
the surface of this structure.
I think you can also see from
this general view the interest
in ornamentation.
You can see that perhaps much
better here, in these details.
Here's a detail of one of the
niches.
Some of the statues are still
preserved, with the names of the
figures in Greek down below.
You can see the way in which
they have essentially
dematerialized the piers by
decorating them so extensively.
And this wonderful view up,
where you can see the
variegated marble that is used
here.
You can see the coffered
ceiling.
You can see the deep
undercutting of the capitals,
and the entablature,
and how overly ornamental it
actually is.
And you can also see that in
the uppermost part actually what
they've created here,
in this particular building,
is something that looks very
much,
I think, like the architectural
cages at the upper tier of the
Fourth Style.
And I remind you of a detail of
one of those,
from that fragment from
Herculaneum that shows the same
sort of coffered ceiling and
elements,
as well as the split triangular
pediment,
that we see also in built
architecture in the second
century A.D.
in Ephesus.
The inside of the structure
looked like this.
This is from Ward-Perkins,
showing you one main niche;
a couple of other tiers with
columns, much simpler inside,
as you can see.
The niches had shelves,
and this is where the scrolls
were kept, in the library.
And here a niche,
beneath which was a place for
the last resting place of
Celsus.
I mentioned this to you when we
talked about the paper topics,
that Celsus wanted--he built
this library as a benefaction to
his city,
to benefit the citizenry
obviously of the city,
as well as to have a building
to put his name on.
But he liked it so much,
and it meant so much to him,
that he decided to make it his
own tomb.
He was buried in his library,
beneath that central niche;
you see it in plan here,
the location of that central
niche--
so as he could be in the midst
of this extraordinary building
that he built,
in perpetuity.
Another showpiece done in this
same ancient Roman baroque style
is the one that you see here,
in a restored view,
from the Ward-Perkins textbook.
It dates to the early second
century A.D.
It's a nymphaeum,
or a fountain,
located at Miletus in Turkey.
We see it here.
And it was also an
extraordinary structure.
It was much more ostentatious
than it needed to be;
it could get the job done with
a lot less.
Its purpose was to serve as a
fountain.
You've got the basin down below.
You could do this with a single
story certainly.
But they built up three stories
in this particular place.
They've been as ostentatious as
they possibly can.
They've spent as much money as
Because I think it was a form
of one-upsmanship from one city
to the next;
you know, I have a better
fountain than you've got,
or I've got a more ornate
was the whole idea;
our city is doing particular
well, because you can see what
prosperity has wrought by this
amazing fountain that we've been
able to build for the
benefaction of the people of the
city of Miletus.
And you can see that the scheme
is the same.
It looks back certainly to the
theatrical architecture,
to the Second Style painting
and Fourth Style painting that
we've talked about here.
The same general idea,
with the first story a series
of double columns with straight
entablatures above;
in the second story the
addition of pediments,
in this case triangular
pediments combined with these
interesting scroll motifs over
some of the pairs of columns.
And then in the uppermost
story, triangular pediments once
again,
niches behind them and between
them,
with statuary,
as you can also see,
and then pilasters,
decorative pilasters on the
wall.
This one also has wings,
but you can see that the wings
are even more elaborate than the
wings we've seen in any of the
other structures,
and they, in fact,
have pediments that face in
toward the central part of the
structure and toward the
fountain proper.
Ward-Perkins has added a few
figures here that give you a
sense once again of the enormity
of the scale of this amazing
fountain in the city of Miletus.
I mentioned that although I was
going to concentrate today on
baroque architecture in the
eastern part of the Empire,
I would show at least one
example from the West,
and I show that to you here.
It takes us back to North
Africa, to a place called
Sabratha, which is located in
between Timgad and Leptis Magna,
that we looked at last time.
Here's the site of Sabratha,
and you can see that it too is
located on the sea.
An extraordinary theater was
built there,
and it's another example of the
way in which these baroque
façades could be used for
a whole host of buildings;
it could be used for theaters
and for temples and for
fountains and for libraries and
so on and so forth.
But theater architecture it was
particularly appropriate for,
because we've seen,
from the very beginning of
Rome,
that these kinds of ornate
columnar schemes were used quite
frequently in theatrical
architecture.
We are looking at the exterior
of the Theater at Sabratha,
which you can see from your
Monument List dates to around
A.D.
200.
It has been re-erected.
Much of it had fallen down,
but once again there was quite
a bit of--the stone was there,
and so they re-erected the
façade.
You can see that it,
like pretty much everything
we've looked at today,
was made out of local stone.
And you can also see two tiers.
And you can see that although
it's made out of local stone,
it is very similar to the sort
of thing we saw much earlier in
Rome itself.
Think of the Theater of
Marcellus.
Think of the Colosseum:
the scheme of arches with
pilasters or columns in between
them, engaged into the wall,
as you can see so well here.
If you look at the view on the
left,
you will see however that the
stage building of the Theater at
Sabratha is particularly well
preserved,
and I want to show you two
views, two spectacular views,
this one in particular,
which shows you what this
structure looked like in
antiquity and what it looks like
now.
And it is another one of these
extraordinary baroque facades,
again so typical for theatrical
architecture.
We see the three great niches,
as we often do--
think of the plan of the
Augustan Theater at Leptis
Magna,
for example--three great
niches, these columnar elements
on either side,
in three stories,
no straddling here,
they are just on top one
another, as you can see well,
but a series of four instead of
the usual two.
But then within the niches
they've also created these
elements, in this case with two
columns that project;
they're inside the niche,
they're contained inside the
niche, but they project in front
of the niche,
adding even more enlivenment to
the structure.
Look down below also.
We rarely have the bottom of
the stage preserved,
but we have it preserved here,
and preserved extremely well.
The bottom of the stage has
been scalloped.
It has projecting elements,
with columns.
And the whole thing is
decorated with sculpture -- so
many figures that those figures
seem to almost dematerialize the
stone.
A crowd of figures,
not just a few figures that you
can read very well,
but a whole host,
crowds of figures,
that show again this interest
in over-decoration in these
baroque buildings.
Here's another view,
not quite as clear,
but I think a very good one,
that also gives you a very good
sense,
not only of the stage
decoration, but of the scale of
the structure,
because we've got a few
tourists standing here,
which show you that once again
bigger is better is clearly the
rallying call of the day.
Here's a detail of some of that
decoration: gods and goddesses
and the like.
We see the Three Graces here,
for example.
But you can see the way they
are crowded in,
to give one a sense of a kind
of excess ornamentation,
which was obviously very
popular during this period.
The last set of buildings that
I want to show you are in many
respects the most interesting of
all,
and this is a group of
buildings that are part of a
complex in what is now Lebanon,
the city of Baalbek.
The so- called Sanctuary of
Jupiter Heliopolitanus at
Baalbek, which was constructed
over a 200-year period,
from the mid-first century A.D.
to the mid-third century A.D.
The location of Baalbek is
right over here,
as I said, in modern Lebanon.
And the remains are incredible,
the remains are incredible.
Every so often there's,
you know, often fighting.
This is the Bekaa Valley,
so there's often fighting that
breaks out in this particular
part of the world,
and one worries about these
monuments,
but so far they seem to have
withstood some of the
difficulties that that area has
experienced in recent years.
And you see some of them here
in the--it's nicely silhouetted
against the landscape.
But this gives you a better
idea of what the complex looked
like in antiquity,
and I show it to you here.
Again, it was built over a
series of years.
But let's just talk about it as
a whole, and then I'll break
down the chronology for you.
It had a grand entranceway,
with a single staircase;
façade orientation,
with an arcuated lintel here,
contained within a pediment.
Then, interestingly enough,
you went from that entranceway
into a hexagonal court,
open to the sky.
From the hexagonal court,
into this great open
rectangular space,
surrounded by columns.
A very large altar right here,
to Jupiter,
because the main temple in this
complex was the Temple to
Jupiter,
and you see it also in the
restored view at the back.
So the Altar to Jupiter,
the Temple to Jupiter.
If you look at the Temple to
Jupiter,
you will see it's very similar
to the temples that we've been
looking at over the course of
the semester:
very tall podium,
single staircase,
façade orientation,
deep porch, freestanding
columns in that porch,
and the like.
And you can also see that there
is another temple right outside
the walls of this one.
This is the so-called Temple of
Bacchus,
which is one of the three that
was part of this complex,
that also seems to have had its
own little courtyard.
And then down here,
out of the picture,
a round Temple to Venus that
we're also going to look at.
This is a restored view of the
same,
showing you the entranceway,
the hexagonal court,
the large Temple to Jupiter,
the smaller Temple to Bacchus,
and the forecourt that it too
would have had,
as well as this much less
elaborate entranceway into the
Temple of Bacchus.
This is perhaps the most
spectacular view I've shown you
all semester of anything;
this is really an awesome
photograph, I think,
taken from the air.
Needless to say,
I can't lay credit to this,
since it was taken from the
air.
But you see it here,
and it is an amazing,
amazing photograph,
that really gives you a better
sense than anything else might
of the current remains,
where you can see the entrance
gate.
You can see that the staircase
is a shadow of what it once was;
it was once much wider.
You can see the hexagonal court
from above.
You can see the open
rectangular space.
You can see the bare remains of
the altar.
And you can see the Temple of
Jupiter, which has its podium,
not much of its staircase,
and only six columns still
surviving.
But the Temple of Bacchus
outside the walls,
much better preserved,
and gives us a very good sense
of these temples as a whole.
A plan over here,
showing the same:
the entrance court,
the hexagonal entranceway,
the open rectangular space,
at A the Temple of Jupiter,
B, the Temple of Bacchus.
And here an engraving showing
the entranceway,
with this arcuated lintel,
just as we saw popular in the
Hadrianic period,
and the pediment.
Now the chronology is that the
Temple of Jupiter was built
first, in the mid-first century
A.D.
That's way back,
that's like the time of
Claudius and Nero:
mid-first century A.D.
Then in the second century
there were other additions,
and it was in the third century
that the propylon and the
hexagonal court--
the second century actually was
the open rectangular space was
added in the second century,
and then in the third century
they added the hexagonal court
and the entranceway.
So moving from the back toward
the front.
These are the six columns that
are preserved of the Temple of
Jupiter, at Baalbek.
They are incredibly--the whole
structure is incredibly large.
This is the biggest building
we've seen thus far.
We know there were ten columns
in the front,
nineteen on the sides.
They're again made out of honey
colored local limestone;
I think, as you can see so well
in both of these views.
In this case the podium was 44
feet tall, 44 feet tall.
The podium at the Temple of the
Divi, at the Forum at Leptis
Magna, was 19 feet tall,
and we thought that was big.
This is 44 feet tall,
and the columns were 65 feet
tall.
And remember those columns that
Sulla stole from Greece,
55 feet tall,
for the Temple of Jupiter OMC,
these are ten--are much taller
than that.
So it gives you some sense of
the incredible scale of this
structure.
Here's a plan of the Temple of
Bacchus, the second temple that
I want to show you,
that dates to the mid-second
century A.D.
We see it here.
You can get a very good sense
of its structure,
and you can see the way in
which it combines typical Roman
with Greek features:
single staircase,
façade orientation,
deep porch, freestanding
columns in the porch,
single cella.
But it has a peripteral
colonnade, as one finds in Greek
architecture.
But it doesn't have a
peripteral staircase,
as I'll show in a moment;
it has rather a high podium.
Here you see it.
It is very well preserved.
You can see the columns
encircling the whole building.
But you can see there is no
staircase circling the whole
building, but a very high
podium.
A few people here for scale.
This is a big building,
and this building is much
smaller than the Temple of
Jupiter.
These buildings are so big that
someone,
I guess tongue in cheek,
wrote an article at one point
suggesting that this could not
have been built by human beings,
Romans or otherwise,
and was definitely built by
Martians who came down in a
spaceship and built it and then
left,
but left us with something
quite extraordinary,
if that was indeed the case.
Once again overly decorative,
overly decorative.
If you look at--we could look
at a whole host of details,
but if you look at them you
will see extraordinary things.
We're looking up in one of the
vaults, and you can see how it's
been nearly pretty much eaten
away by this excessive
decoration.
The same here with this
wonderful Medusa head in the
center.
No inch is left undecorated by
these architects.
This is one of the
best-preserved interiors of a
Roman temple that we have,
the Temple of Bacchus.
We are looking through the
doorway.
If you look at the jambs of the
doorway,
you will see how decorated they
are,
and again the way in which they
have been dematerialized through
that ornamentation.
Looking into the interior--and
I can show you a better view
here--
you get a very good sense of
what this structure looked like
in antiquity:
the truly colossal Corinthian
columns,
in this particular case,
the niches on two stories,
with arcuated pediments and
with triangular pediments up
above--
the extraordinary scale of this
highly decorative interior.
And I can show you a restored
view of what we think this
looked like in antiquity.
At first glance it doesn't look
so different from the sort of
Basilica Ulpia idea in Rome,
with the flat ceiling,
the coffered ceiling,
the giant columns and so on.
But, of course,
it has no aisles,
since it's--I mean,
it does, I'm sorry,
it does have aisles here.
But you can see the arcuations;
you can see the pediments,
with the sculpture inside.
You can see the Corinthian
capitals.
And you can see no clerestory
here.
But you can see a very
interesting feature at the end.
The focus of everyone who came
into this temple was the
so-called adyton,
a-d-y-t-o-n,
adyton,
which is a kind of shrine in
which the cult statue of Bacchus
would have been presented.
You can see it well here.
And you can see the use of the
broken triangular pediment,
but one that is very similar to
that market gate in that the
central element,
with its triangle,
still preserved,
but preserved in a plane that
is further back --
so that kind of zigzag motion
that we see here.
The great archivolt underneath,
the paired columns on either
side, the shrine in the center.
A very elaborate motif,
done in the style that we have
described as baroque for this
incredible structure.
I want to end today by showing
you my favorite of all the
buildings that I've shown you
today,
because it's so eccentric,
and that is the Temple of Venus
at Baalbek.
It's the small temple that lies
outside the complex,
to the left of the complex,
in the front.
And it's the latest of the
three temples--it probably dates
to early--to mid-third century
A.D.--and also by far the
smallest;
it's very small in relationship
to the others.
It is also a round temple,
unlike them,
which are the traditional
rectangular temples,
a round temple.
But a round temple with a
difference.
If we look at the plan,
we will see it has a single
staircase, a façade
orientation, deep porch,
freestanding columns in that
porch.
It also is peripteral;
it has columns that go all the
way around.
It is a round structure with a
round cella.
But you can see in plan that
the architect has scalloped the
outside of the structure,
in a very interesting way,
and you can see that also in
these restored views over here
--
that scalloping,
both on the base and also in
the area of the entablature
above the columns.
You can also see that the
architect has placed niches on
the outside of the structure,
with statues in them,
which is another example of
this desire to decorate every
surface that one possibly could.
There's a great deal of
controversy as to what the porch
actually looked like:
whether the porch had what we
see here,
which is an arcuated lintel
inside a triangular pediment.
That's possible.
It may not have had that,
we're not absolutely sure.
But at the very least we have
this combination of what seems
like a relatively traditional
porch, with an innovative body.
It is, in a sense,
a small version,
and a very eccentric version,
of the Pantheon in Rome,
with that traditional porch and
revolutionary body.
But this is not made out of
concrete, it is made entirely
out of local stone.
And again it has these
wonderful features,
like the scalloped base.
And I show you a detail.
It's very well preserved today,
as are the other buildings,
or at least the Temple of
Bacchus at Baalbek.
We see it here.
You can see its stone
construction.
Unfortunately it's black and
white, but you can get a sense;
it's the same honey colored
stone as the others.
You can see the way it looks
here.
You can see the scalloped base;
the scalloped,
the wonderful scalloped
entablature, and,
the overly decorative nature of
that entablature.
Above, in this case Corinthian
capitals, as you can see.
Some traditional motifs,
like these hanging garlands.
The niches here with the
statuary, making the whole into
a kind of decorative motif;
even the outside of the cella
becomes decorative.
But look very carefully and you
will see that the bases of the
columns are five-sided,
to make them work better with
the scalloped wall.
This is the second time we've
seen bases like this.
We saw them in the Tomb of
Annia Regilla in Rome,
a base that had multiple--more
sides than was usual.
We see that here,
and it's a testimony again to
the eccentricity of this
particular designer,
but also to the sort of
anything-goes approach that we
see in so much of this Roman
baroque architecture.
And I just, in closing,
the last two images that I'd
like to show you are a detail of
the Temple of Venus at Baalbek,
with a temple--with a detail of
a Borromini structure.
This one is the Borromini
structure.
This one is the Temple of Venus.
But I think when you look at
views like this,
you can see the close--you can
see what I mean by defining
these as baroque buildings,
already in Roman antiquity --
but you can see the
extraordinary impact that these
amazing Roman creations had on
the minds and on the
oeuvres of great
architects,
like Bernini and Borromini,
in the seventeenth century in
Italy.
Thank you very much.